[music]
I feel like we haven't done this for a
long time um because we missed the last
one. So, we're going to jump right in.
We have a bunch of resolutions
um to discuss
and then
after we go through those we're going to
kind of
and meeting prep will kind of premise
what we're going to do with the ones
that should have been introduced last
meeting so we can keep the timeline
correct on all of those. So we'll go
over those after we do all the
introduction and discussion on those.
So, we're going to start with temporary
resolution 1126 coming through public
works. Mr. Carr.
>> Uh, yes. This is a an annual piece of
legislation to um for LDOT to enter into
the ODOT contract for or to buy salt on
the ODOT contract.
>> And I don't believe there's anyone from
I don't [clears throat]
see them.
>> Anyone have any questions on that? Like
Mr. car said it is an annual piece
and we're probably going to need some. I
would assume
>> we may have depleted this the supply.
>> Yeah.
>> Okay. And then I have Mr. Sully as your
second.
>> Okay.
All right. Temporary resolution 1226.
That's coming through water water
pollution. Mr. Als
12 and 13. They're both annual pieces. U
we have a water department, we need
chemicals, and we need pipe and
fittings. So, this is the piece of
legislation that allows us to purchase
those. Pretty straightforward.
>> Yes, sir. Any questions on those two?
Okay.
Temporary resolution 1426, that's coming
through finance. Um that's amending
appropriations
in the escrow fund for the northwater
treatment plant. Um Auditor Nettle spoke
to that last time, gave us a heads up
that that was coming. Um we can discuss
that again if we want, but essentially
Kakosing took the draw down.
>> What?
What?
>> Sorry, Mr. Skunover. if you could remind
everybody to use microphones uh and
speak up. Uh we're hearing from the
audience that people are not able to
hear us very well.
>> You can't hear me?
>> That is odd.
>> Okay, my microphone's on so I'm like I
don't have volume control. I'm like I
don't
>> I don't know. All right, can you hear me
now?
>> Okay, perfect. They all shake their
heads. Yeah, this is awesome. This is a
great class. I appreciate you. When we
get to the hairy part later, continue to
nod whether it's right or wrong. Nod.
Yes. Okay.
Okay. So again, that is draw down from
cocoa that Auditor Nettle spoke about.
So we're making that account right with
this piece. Any [snorts] questions?
Okay.
All right. Temporary resolution 1526
that's coming through safety committee.
Uh looks like what Mr. AUG speak to this
one.
>> Uh yes, this is for a uh grant coming
from uh the Bureau of Workers
Compensation
uh allowing [clears throat]
a uh
uh grant for a CPR
uh automated CPR machine.
And uh that'll bring us up to uh three
CPR machines. So, we'll have one at each
firehouse.
>> Perfect. And then I have Well, I'm going
to be your second.
And any questions on that piece?
So, authorizing to accept a grant for
CPR machine for fire. All right.
Temporary resolution 1626 that's coming
through public works. Mr. car.
>> This is a resolution to authorize the
surface safety director to enter into
grant agreements and to uh enter into
the contracts for various consultants
for the east side industrial uh
connector project. Um service safety
director Woody, would you like to uh
comment on this?
[clears throat]
>> Yeah, I will just add this is something
>> I'm sorry I didn't see that I bring Kurt
uh Kurt Shawn from the engineers uh
office up to
>> Well, I see I've been booted to the
curb.
>> Well, [laughter]
>> it's good to be Kurt Shaw.
>> I did not see him. you can you can speak
as well if you'd like. So,
>> uh so this is if you remember we had a
planning study performed a few years ago
now it's been for the east side
industrial connector a better way to get
uh across town instead of using Main
Street. There's an alternate corridor
that was identified in that planning
study. Um, we took that information and
applied to the to Federal Highway for a
build grant and we were awarded $800,000
to continue the study of that corridor.
It'll be a a feasibility study.
I'm working with FHWA
trying to get through to get an
agreement. Uh, right now it's in a draft
form. I expect that agreement to come in
um soon, very soon. I've been saying
that for a month, but um and when we get
that, what this legislation does allows
us to enter into an agreement and to
hire an engineering outfit to do that uh
feasibility study. And what they will do
will be public involvement meetings and
different u environmental reviews of
that corridor. Try to identify uh any of
the big cost items that would be
associated with that and they will look
at alternates
um in that study.
Any questions?
[snorts]
>> Thank you.
And I have Miss Smiley as your second on
that one, Mr. Carr.
>> Okay.
All right. Temporary resolution 1726.
That's coming through. Water water
pollution. Mr. Als,
>> can we do 17, 18, 19, and 21? And bring
Curtis up one time.
>> Sure.
>> He's here.
>> Yeah, absolutely. Thank you all. Um so
these three pieces are annual pieces of
legislation for water pollution control
department. The first one being a fund
of fund transfer with then announced
certificates for the wastewater
replacement improvement fund. The second
is a planned and budgeted transfer to
satisfy the requirements of our bond
covenant and to maintain our bond
rating. And the third is to it
appropriates unspent balances carried
over from 2025 within the wastewater
replacement and improvement fund
>> and then 21 while you're
>> Yeah, absolutely. Um, this piece of
legislation is to reappropriate unspent
balances within the wastewater utility
reserve fund. And this is due to the
status of contracts at the end of 2025.
Um, what is currently approved in the
2026 budget does not include all of the
necessary funds for the 2026 projects.
>> Any questions?
>> Thank you. Thank you.
two readings on all of those suspending
on 21. [snorts]
>> Okay.
>> All right. That bumps us down to
temporary resolution 2026 coming through
the service committee. Mr. Nley.
>> Yep. Thank you, Mr. Chairman. Uh this is
uh from the parks department. This is
for uh phase one of the Miller Park
redevelopment project. Uh this is for
the parks department to [snorts] enter
into an agreement with uh a company for
final engineering design services on
phase one of the project. Um and uh I
don't know if anyone here from the parks
department would like to speak.
>> Absolutely. But um that's kind of the
overview of the legislation here.
>> Thank you. Good evening members council
and chairman. Um this is the fourth step
in the process of getting Miller Park
the redesign done. Started a couple
years ago. So there's been a lot of
interest from the community um when the
water plant started what was going to
happen with Miller Park and this is part
of that process. Um we've been working
on this for about I've been back here
three years. I've been working on it for
three years. We have a community
coalition of people um with one of the
Rotary clubs and the all accessible ball
field group. We've raised over $2
million towards this project. So, we've
got a lot of community support and what
we're doing tonight is asking for your
permission to go ahead and enter into a
contract with EMH&T who did the concept
design. They were selected through a
competitive RFQ process, request for
qualification process. Um, we're asking
for permission to move forward with the
contract, appropriate the money to pay
for the contract out of the park fund,
and then have the auditor do her auditor
magic to make it right when within the
uh Trish isn't here, but it's auditor
magic, and I don't understand it, but
she does it. So, any questions, please?
>> No.
>> Okay. Thank you. And then
same two readings, Miss Hoop as your
second. Okay.
All right. We're going to jump to
temporary resolution 2226.
That is coming through finance then and
now for bill payment for contract
services.
Miss Woody, was that that was the one
you were
your baby?
for the 2023 or for the 2326
22.
>> Oh, my apologies. Sorry. Um and yes,
that is for my office. We have a grant
writer and
I this is on me. Uh, so at the end of
the year, we do carry over purchase
orders and I have a new office manager
and so I instructed her to carry over
all of our purchase orders, but forgot
to tell her the second step, which is to
encumber the entire amount that she
needs for that purchase order. And so
she did carry over the purchase order
like she was supposed to, but uh she
didn't know uh to encumber the whole
amount for that invoice. So we cannot
pay off of that purchase order, which
then requires a now certificate. So, my
apologies. That is on me. Uh, I am
asking for suspension so that we can pay
this invoice. We have the money. It was
already budgeted for. Um, I just forgot
her forgot to tell her step two of the
process for Auditor Nettles.
>> Okay.
Any questions on that one?
And I will be [clears throat] asking for
suspension on that for you.
All right. Temporary resolution 2326
that's coming through safety committee.
Mr. Bisjack.
>> Thank you, Mr. Chair. This is uh
legislation here to accept around
$97,000 in CPT state grant money. Money
that is uh being provided to us from the
Ohio Attorney General's office. Um this
is once again a reimbursement for our
police officers who go out to get
necessary certifications and lensures
for them to do their jobs essentially.
Um, this is a reimbursement from 2000 or
yeah, from 2024. Um, since there's kind
of a two-year delay to this. Um, and the
funds that we get reimbured for today
help offset the costs that our police
officers incur currently right now for
training. So, it's so essentially the
follow the money trail. It's going from
the attorney general's office into
unencumbered funds, which is then going
to the 2047 fund specifically for
training. Uh, that specific line item.
So, that's all I have. We're going the
full three readings. Mr. Chair, and Mr.
Si is my second.
>> Awesome. Thank you. Any questions on
that one?
Okay.
2426. That's also through safety
committee.
Uh that one um is a then and now uh uh
piece of legislation to help essentially
pay for January's expensive expenses for
the uh LPD unmarked fleet. um due to the
turnover in terms and everything like
that, you know, they got the bill
January 1, but they have the money. They
just need to pay for it now. The money's
already been encumbered and sent aside,
so no new money being spent here. And uh
Mr. Og will be my second, and I'll be
going suspension on this one.
>> Okay. Any questions on 2426?
Seeing none.
Oh, I don't I'm not aware of any other
ordinances that we need to discuss. Were
there
we'll talk about that in a minute.
>> You said ordinances resolutions.
>> Yeah. No more resolutions. You got it.
Smarty pants in the class. It's always
the lawyer.
>> Well, I was She gave me a hard time
earlier, so that's what we're doing
here.
Okay.
There's always one
new ordinances.
Okay. Temporary ordinance 226 that is
coming through public works. It would be
with Mr. Carr.
>> Thank you, Mr. President. Um, this is
rightway acquisition for the Memorial
Pierce Whittier sidewalk project. So,
that's the area along in front of uh
Sheets through that section of Memorial
Drive. Um, city engineer Shank, would
you like to come up and comment on that?
Good evening. This is the
second phase of this project. We
received a corpo grant to do the
engineering for sidewalks along Memorial
Drive from Whittier to Arlington and
then also along Pierce Avenue
from Memorial down to the Mumus.
Um those engineering plans are finished.
We applied for another corpo grant to
pay for the ride ofway. We needed to
purchase right ofway to get this project
done and that's what this
ordinance is for to allow us to acquire
that ride ofway.
>> Any questions for Mr. Chunk?
>> No.
>> This will be two readings and Mr.
Bisjack will be my second.
>> Great. Thanks. Thanks, Kurt.
Uh, ordinance temporary ordinance 326
that's coming through finance. Um, this
is the
we're asking for suspension on this.
This is the
correction to one that we passed
previously for the fire department. Miss
Wood, do you want to speak to that one?
>> Absolutely. So, if you recall, we did
pay ordinances. uh we passed those back
in December uh the management ordinance
and when we submitted the request for
legislation we had made a revision to
that. However, in
in the in the process that revision did
not make it to what you approved on
council floor. Um so this had already
been discussed back in December. Um it
is to revert back to the old structure
in our fire department. We used to have
two assistant fire chiefs. In 2010, that
changed to one assistant fire chief, but
we would like to go back to two
assistant fire chiefs. I did send all of
the supporting documentation to the
safety committee, and we talked about
that in our safety council committee um
last week um as well as the uh finance
committee. And
I think that when they made the change
back in 2010, it was based off of
financial reasons. They thought that it
would save some money. What we're
finding is it really has not saved any
money and we're asking currently our
battalion chief to
fulfill a role and act in the capacity
of an assistant fire chief. Um, however,
it's not an assistant fire chief's
position in the pay ordinance. So, it's
it's very difficult from a management
side of things and an HR side of things
to have him act in that capacity when
it's not an assistant chief's position.
So we did go to civil service commission
that was approved back at the beginning
of December to abolish the third
battalion chief position and then
reinstate the second assistant assistant
chief position. However, to make it
official on our payroll for the
auditor's records, uh we need to have
that again just amended in the pay
ordinance since we since it did not make
it through council floor back in
December.
>> Okay. Thank you. Any questions on that?
So, same piece that we've seen
fixing fixing it third times a charm.
Yes. Okay. [snorts] And then I will be
asking for suspension on that this
evening.
Those are all of the new ordinances we
need to introduce.
So, I will entertain anyone for
department updates.
Anyone
here for department updates?
Awesome. Thank you. Again, I I'm
cheering on this class. This is amazing.
Oh,
sorry. I had to. So Darren Drum is not
here this evening, but I would be remiss
if I did not just give a shout out to
our water department and our
distribution guys for I believe we're up
to 25 water main breaks in the city of
Lancaster in the last three weeks. And
our distribution guys have been working
around the clock um for the last three
weeks trying to keep water flowing to
our residents and keep our streets safe
from water flowing out and turning into
ice. Um, and Darren's not here tonight
because they are again working on a
water mane. Uh, so again, kudos to our
water department, Darren and his entire
crew for all [snorts] of the water main
breaks that they've been handling over
the last three weeks. And of course, in
case you missed it, we did have a crazy
snow event over the last two weeks. So
again, a shout out to uh Tim Deetsz and
his street department for keeping the
streets clean and plowed. Um there's not
a lot of places to put snow other than
the curb, which then starts to impede
the sidewalk. So again, thanks to
everybody who's helped. Um I know
residents have been working fast and
furious to keep the sidewalks clean and
LDOT's been working fast and furious to
keep the ramps accessible to get to the
sidewalks and keep our streets clean. So
again, thanks to everybody over the last
couple weeks for really pulling together
and helping during this crazy snowstorm
and the freezing cold frigen
temperatures.
All right. Thank you. Anybody else for
department updates?
Seeing none, we're going to move on to
council meeting prep. And as you can
see, we played musical chairs. The mayor
is out of town. So, President Porter is
sitting over there. I'm sitting here.
So, I'm going to be running uh the
meeting tonight. I do just so
I think everybody around the table has
this sorted out, right? So just for
everybody else watching. So resolutions
1 through
that are on the agenda as second
reading. Those were all going to be
second read second of most of them were
going to be second of three readings
last time. So to keep everything kind of
moving forward, they're all second
reading. We're going to be doing a bunch
of suspensions. We're going to be doing
a few of those suspensions at once to
kind of just put it all together. Be
efficient. Efficiency is a word of mine
I use all day every day. And that's what
we're trying to do here. And then
everything that we discussed
over the last few minutes are your first
readings. Um so we essentially made
those all two readings instead of three
because of the again twoe delay on
those. So there's a few suspension
scattered in there. I think were there a
couple that we had to replace with star
versions?
>> Nine and 10. nine and 10.
Okay.
So, you're going to replace those first
and then ask for suspension on
>> Yes.
>> Okay. All right.
>> I'm ready.
>> Yeah. I was just making sure I had it
right and everybody else is fine.
Okay.
And then we do have a public hearing
as well.
That's why you're sitting over there.
I'm talking to Mr. Porter.
30 ordinances and a public hearing. And
>> you're still in line of my bad eyes.
>> It's probably a good idea.
Just kidding. Okay.
Anything else from meeting prep? Do we
Everyone knows what's going on. I think
I know what's going on. Okay. And then
any other discussion items for finance?
Still a quiet class. I'm I'm digging it.
All right, we're going to I'm going to
ask for a motion to adjurnn.
>> So move.
>> Second.
>> Motion from Sullie, second from Als.
All right. So we are adjourned at 6:22.
The regular meeting will start on time
at 6:30.
have a long and wonderful history
[music] of serving our community. Feel
free to give us a call at 740-653652.
Stop in and see us at either of our two
locations, 405 North Columbus Street in
Lancaster [music]
and 207 South Main Street in Baltimore.
Respect for tradition, [music] regard
for change.
Great automotive service is just around
the corner at the Buckeye family of
dealerships. Whether it's Buckeye Nissan
in Hillyard, Georgeesville Nissan
[music] at the Georgeesville Auto Mall,
Buckeye Honda of Lancaster, Buckeye
Toyota of Lancaster, or Buckeye
Collision Center in Hillyard. Team
Buckeye services [music] all makes and
models at each location, utilizing
modern practices with hundreds of years
of experience, giving you peace of mind.
That's how we Buckeye.
Evening everybody. Um,
I don't have a a prayer. Uh, as per
usual, I have my words of wisdom. And,
uh, today, besides the reminder of the
art of neighboring, uh, show some grace.
I mean, I don't I have to be on social
media for certain reasons, but you when
we're talking about removing snow, when
we're talking about anything else, just
show some grace. That's that's my words
of wisdom today. All right. All right.
Pledge of allegiance.
I pledge algiance to the flag of the
United States of America and to the
republic for which it stands. One nation
under God, indivisible, with liberty and
justice for all.
>> My watch didn't understand what I was
saying.
Okay. I didn't really call the meeting
to order, so I'm doing that now. And if
I could
have the clerk call the role.
>> Mr. Als here.
>> Mr. Bisjack
>> here.
>> Mr. Carr
>> Miss Cohen
>> here.
>> Mrs. Who
>> Mr. Nicely
>> here.
>> Mr. OG
>> here. Mr. Skunover
>> here
>> and Mr. Sullie
>> here.
>> Uh,
can I get a motion? We have nine of 10
members. Can I get a motion to excuse
Miss Smiley, please?
>> Second.
>> Miss Cohen with the first, Mr. Bisjack
with a second. Miss Smiley is
excused. Reading and disposal of the
journal. I have reading um regular
meeting minutes dated January 12th,
2026.
>> I guess
>> do the first you Yeah. Will you do the
first and the second? You want me to?
>> Yeah.
>> All right.
>> I have to practice everything. I can't
just do it on
>> I got it.
I'd like to make a motion to receive and
file the journal. Second.
>> Thank you.
>> A motion [snorts] and let's say I had to
do motion and second to receive and file
the journal. All in favor signify by
saying I.
>> All oppose same size sign. Motion
carries. Reports of city officials.
>> I have six of them. I have email data
January 23rd 2026 regarding the Langster
ESID 2025 resolutions. um
to be signed um submitted by law
director Stephanie Hall. Email dated
January 3rd, 2026 regarding 2025
Lancaster Law Director and City
Prosecutor annual report submitted by
law director Stephanie Hall. Email dated
January 20th, 2026 regarding the
February 12th, 2026 planning commission
submitted by city planner Chas Carter.
Email dated January 25th, 2026 regarding
legislation for 2020 January 2026.
Submitted by environmental engineer
Denise Cruz. Series of emails between
Steven Gayfield, the park superintendent
and council member Larry Als dated
February 2nd, 2026 regarding legislation
for Miller Park redevelopment.
Email dated February 5th, 2026 regarding
January 2026 income tax collection
report submitted by income tax
commissioner Andy Hamilton.
>> Thank you. I'd like to make a motion to
receive and file the reports to city
officials.
>> Second.
>> We have a motion and a second to accept
and file the reports of city officials.
All in favor, please signify by saying
I. I.
>> All oppose, same sign. Motion carries.
Do we have any communications?
>> I have three of them. I have email data
January 28, 2026 regarding child abuse
prevention submitted by Angela
Patterson. Email data January 30th, 2026
regarding the public records request on
purchasing data submitted by Justin
Winnig with Bridgear or Starbridge Data
Hub. Email dated February 5th, 2026
regarding the Langster Police
Department. Submitted by Amy Schlick.
I'd like to make a motion to receive and
file the communications.
>> Second.
>> A motion and a second to accept and file
the communications. All in favor, please
signify by saying I.
>> I. All
>> post same sign. Motion carries.
Do we're not aware. Do we have any
special presentations and awards?
>> Do we have any petitions and memorials?
>> There are no petitions or memorials this
evening. [clears throat]
Okay, now's the time we set aside for
voters or taxpayers to address counsel.
Are there any Is there anyone here that
would like to speak before council this
evening?
No.
Moving on. Reports of standing
committees.
>> I do have nine this evening. I have
economic development committee meeting
dates dated January 12th, 2026 submitted
by Mrs. Hoop. Safety Committee meeting
dates dated January 12th, 2026.
Submitted by Mr. Bisjack. Water, water,
pollution meeting dates January dated
January 13, 2026 submitted by Mr. Als.
Finance committee meeting agenda dated
January 14th, 2026. Submitted by Mr.
Skunover. Service committee meeting
dates dated January 23rd, 2026,
submitted by Mr. Nicely. Administrative
committee meeting dates dated January
27th, 2026. Uh, submitted by Miss Cohen.
Finance Committee meeting agenda dated
February 6, 2026. Submitted by Mr.
Skunover. Safety Committee meeting
agenda dated February 4th, 2026,
submitted by Mr. Bisjack. Economic
development committee meeting minutes
February
dated February 9th, 2026. Submitted by
Mrs. Soup
>> like to make a motion to receive and
file the reports of standing committees.
>> Second. [snorts]
>> We have a excuse me, we have a motion
and a second to accept the report to
special committees.
>> Standing.
>> Yeah, sorry. Standing committees. All in
favor, please signify by saying I.
>> I.
>> All post same sign.
>> Motion carries. Are there any reports of
special committees?
>> There are no reports.
>> Okay.
>> We do have a public hearing scheduled
for this evening on temporary ordinance
126.
Um do we have anyone here that is come
to speak for or against temporary
ordinance 126?
Seeing none. So,
>> so I'm going to open the public hearing
Law Director Hall.
>> Yeah, that'd be great. Sorry.
Thank you.
>> Good evening. Um, just a reminder, this
is for the reszoning of I think believe
it was
um 1560 East Main Street. It was
previously or it's currently zoned
mobile home community and we are um
requesting to change the zoning to
commercial general.
>> Does anyone have any questions on that
or why we're doing that?
Yeah. Can I just follow up? Um, so we're
doing it because back in 2023 when we
amended the zoning map and updated all
of the districts, um, the property
surrounding it was mobile home community
and they felt like they might be um,
spot zoning if they changed the zoning
or if they didn't change the zoning
rather on the parcel in question to
match. Um however it was commercial
general at the time and the property
owners would like it to go back to
commercial general because they intend
to develop it um for some purpose and
they can't do that if it is mobile home
community. So that's the reason if
anybody has any other questions.
>> Okay.
>> Just to clarify it's an empty lot right
now. Nobody's living on it. There's no
mobile homes or anything on it.
>> Correct. Yes.
>> Okay. And then
I have public comment. Nobody is here
for that. So we had would have
proponents opponents come and speak. We
don't have any of that. So we're going
to go ahead and close this
public hearing. All right. Thanks,
Chess.
We're going to move on to reading of
resolutions.
We have no third readings tonight, so
we're going to move straight into second
reading. Starting with temporary resol
temporary resolution 126.
>> I have a resolution authorizing the
Lancaster Police Department to apply for
the 2026 2027 drug use prevention grant.
This is through safety committee. Mr.
Bisjack and Mr. Sully.
>> Mr. Bisjack.
>> Thank you, Mr. President. I move that
council suspend its rules and wave the
third reading for the resolution
temporarily numbered 1-26.
>> Second.
>> Have a motion and a second to suspend
second third readings on temporary
resolution 126. Mr. Bisjack.
>> Uh that was already addressed in the
finance committee. I have nothing
further to add. Thank you, Mr.
President.
>> Anyone else? Seeing none, please call
the role.
>> Mr. Aos,
>> yes.
>> Mr. Bisjack,
>> Mr. Carr,
>> yes.
>> Mr. Co. Miss Cohen.
>> Yes.
>> Mrs. Who?
>> Yes. Mr. Nisley.
>> Yes.
>> Mr. OG.
>> Mr. Skoover.
>> Yes.
>> And Mr. Sully.
>> Temporary suspension. A temporary
resolution 126
passes 9 to zero. Mr. Bisjack.
>> Uh, thank you, Mr. President. I move
that council pass engross and enter upon
the written record the resolution
temporarily numbered 1-26.
>> Second. A motion and a second to pass
temporary resolution 126.
Any discussion?
>> Uh thank you, Mr. President. Just a
friendly reminder to all that this
resolution once again authorizes the
Lancaster Police Department to pursue
funding for the 2026 2027 year uh for
drug use preventions essentially to help
provide uh reimbursement for our two
DARE officers and LPD that go to our
schools. Great.
>> So that's all. Thank you, Mr. President.
>> Any other questions?
Seeing none, please call the role.
>> Mr. Als,
>> yes.
>> Mr. Bisjack,
>> Mr. Carr,
>> yes.
>> Miss Cohen,
>> Mrs. Hoop,
>> yes.
>> Mr. Nisley,
>> Mr. Al,
>> yes.
>> Mr. Skunover,
>> And Mr. Salty,
>> yes.
[snorts]
>> Temporary resolution 126 passes 9 to
zero. Temporary resolution 226. A
resolution authorizing city departments
to dispose of city property no longer
needed by internet auction in 2026 and
declaring emergency. This is through
administrative services committee. Miss
Cohen and Mrs. Hoop.
>> Miss Cohen.
>> Are we going to read them all?
>> All right. So, we're going to read 2
through six.
>> Correct. 2 through six. Okay. Um,
resolution temporary number 3-26, a
resolution authorizing the city of
Lancaster to join the cooperative
council of governments and participate
in the Equalist Group Cooperative
Purchasing Program. Again,
administrative services committee, Mrs.
Cohen, Mrs. Hoop or Miss Cohen, Mrs.
Hoop. Resolution temporary 4-26, a
resolution authorizing the city of
Lancaster to participate in the source
cooperative purchasing program again
through administrative services
committee, Miss Cohen and Mr. OG. Um,
resolution temporary 5-26, a resolution
authorizing the city of Lancaster to
participate in the master
intergovernmental cooperative purchasing
agreement administered by Omnia Partners
public sector. this through um again
administrative services committee, Miss
Cohen and Mr. OG. And lastly, a
resolution temporary 6-26, a resolution
authorizing the city of Lancaster to
participate in the state of Ohio
cooperative purchasing program. Um
again, administrative services
committee, Miss Cohen and
um Mr. Al.
>> All right, Miss Cohen.
>> So,
Mr. President, I'd like to make a motion
that council suspend its rules and wave
the third reading of resolutions
temporarily numbered 226, 326, 426, 526,
and 626.
>> Second.
>> Sounds good. All right. We have a motion
in a second to suspend the rules and
wave the second and third readings on
temporary resolution 2, three, four,
five, and 626. Any discussion on any of
those pieces?
No. Seeing none, please call the role.
>> Mr. Als,
>> yes.
>> Mr. Bisjack,
>> Mr. Carr, [clears throat]
>> yes.
>> Miss Cohen,
>> Mrs. Hoop,
>> yes.
>> Mr. Nisley,
>> yes. [snorts]
>> Mr. OG,
>> yes.
>> Mr. Skoover,
>> And Mr. Sully,
>> yes.
>> Motion to suspend passes nine to zero.
Miss Cohen.
>> Uh, Mr. President, I'd like to make a
motion that council pass engross and
enter upon the written record resolution
temporarily numbered 226.
>> Second.
>> All right. We have a motion and a second
to pass temporary resolution 226.
Discussion.
Um, this is, uh, an annual piece of
legislation that allows the city to
dispose of, um, unnecessary and obsolete
items by way of an internet auction. In
the past, we've done a city auction, but
have found that the internet auction um,
provides more funds.
Okay,
>> any questions on that?
Seeing none, call the roll.
>> Mr. Mr. Als,
>> yes.
>> Mr. Bisjack,
>> Mr. Carr,
>> yes.
>> Miss Cohen,
>> Mrs. Hoop,
>> yes.
>> Mr. Nisley,
>> Mr. OG,
>> yes.
>> Mr. Skunover,
>> And Mr. Sully,
>> yes.
>> Motion to pass temporary resolution 226
succeeds 9 to0. Temporary resolution
326.
>> Uh, Mr. President, I'd like to make a
motion that council pass engross and
enter upon the written written record
resolution temporarily numbered 326.
>> Second.
>> We have a motion in a second to pass
temporary resolution 326.
Discussion.
>> Um the next four resolutions are all
annual pieces of legislation that deal
um allow the city to participate in
cooperative
um or joint purchasing programs. Um,
these are a statutory alternative to
competitive bidding for many items um
that saves the city both time and money
by allowing them to um leverage
nationwide purchasing power. So those
that applies to each of the four
resolutions are a different
organization, but they all do the same
thing.
>> Great. Thank you. Any questions on that
or any of those?
All right. So, we have a motion to pass
resolution 326. Please call the role.
>> Mr. Als,
>> yes.
>> Mr. Bisjack,
>> Mr. Carr,
>> yes.
>> Miss Cohen,
>> Mrs. Hoop,
>> yes.
>> Mr. Nisley,
>> Mr. OG,
>> yes.
>> Mr. Skunover,
>> And Mr. Sully,
>> yes.
Temporary resolution 326 passes 9 to0.
Temporary resolution 426.
>> Mr. President, I'd like to make a motion
that council pass and gross and enter
upon the written record resolution
temporarily numbered 426.
>> Second.
>> A motion and a second to pass
temporary resolution 426. Any discussion
other than what we
>> no
>> had before. Thank you. Any other
questions?
Seeing none, please call the role.
>> Mr. A, yes.
>> Mr. Bisjack, yes.
>> Mr. Carr,
>> yes.
>> Miss Cohen,
>> Mrs. Who?
>> Yes.
>> Mr. Nisley?
>> Mr. OG?
>> Yes.
>> Mr. Skoonover?
>> And Mr. Sie?
>> Yes.
>> Temporary resolution 426 passes 9 to0.
Temporary resolution 526.
>> Mr. President, I'd like to make a motion
that council pass and gross and enter
upon the written record. Resolution
temporarily numbered 526.
>> Second.
>> We have a motion and a second to pass
temporary resolution 526.
>> Please call the role.
>> Mr. Als,
>> yes.
>> Mr. Bisjack,
>> Mr. Carr,
>> yes.
>> Miss Cohen,
>> Mrs. Hoop,
>> yes. Mr. Nisley,
>> yes.
>> Mr. Og,
>> Mr. Skunover,
>> yes.
>> And Mr. Sully,
Temporary resolution 526 passes 9 to
zero. Temporary resolution 626.
>> Mr. President, I'd like to make a motion
that council pass and gross and enter
upon the written record resolution
temporarily numbered 626.
>> Second.
>> We have a motion and a second to pass
temporary resolution 626. Please call
the role.
>> Mr. Als,
>> yes.
>> Mr. Bishar,
>> Mr. Carr,
>> yes. Miss Cohen,
>> yes.
>> Mrs. Who?
>> Yes.
>> Mr. Nisley,
>> yes.
>> Mr. OG,
>> Mr. Scoover,
>> yes.
>> And Mr. Sully,
>> Temporary resolution 626 passes 9 to
zero.
>> Temporary [clears throat]
resolution 726,
>> a resolution authorizing the city law
director's office to apply for violence
against women act grant. This is through
law committee. Um,
>> Mr. Mr. Skunover.
And who else?
>> Second.
>> Mr. Hog.
>> Okay. We'll have him do the second.
>> Okay.
>> All right.
I It's me. I'm going to make a motion to
suspend the rules and way the second
third readings of temporary resolution
726.
>> Second. Have a motion and a second to
pass temporary resolution 726.
Any discussion? That's me. But I'm going
to You're good.
>> Motion to suspend.
>> Suspend.
>> Oh, you want to suspend? I'm sorry. Did
I What' I do?
>> You You said pass.
>> Yep.
It's hard to juggle two of these things
when I'm doing this. Okay. So, motion to
suspend the second and third readings.
Please call the role.
>> Mr. Als. Yes,
>> Mr. Bisjack.
>> Yes,
>> Mr. Carr.
>> Miss Cohen.
>> Yes,
>> Mrs. Hoop.
>> Mr. Nisley.
>> No,
>> Mr. OG.
>> Yes,
>> Mr. Skoover. [snorts]
>> Yes.
>> And Mr. Sully?
>> Motion to suspend passes 8 to one.
I'm going to make a motion to
pass and gross and enter upon the
written record temporary resolution 726.
>> Second.
>> Second. A motion and a second.
[clears throat] Discussion.
Mr. Nisley.
>> Yeah. Thanks, Mr. President. Um, I am
opposed to this resolution. I plan on
voting no for a few reasons. Um, number
one being I don't believe that the city
of Lancaster should serve as a data
collection arm for the federal
government, which this this U grant part
does in part. Um, I believe that um I
also I also have concerns with due
process and gun rights when it comes to
the Violence Against Women Act. Um, I
believe that this uh this program uh
incentivizes the aggressive promotion of
of u policy that um regarding civil
orders that result in the um the the
seizure of firearms and the the
revocation of gun rights for a lot of
people sometimes before due process even
takes place. Um I also have some some
concerns. I've done some research and uh
I believe that this the violence against
women act also [snorts]
forces certain um DEI and gender
identity requirements upon the city and
uh all the grantees and so for those
reasons I will be opposed to this um
resolution. Thank you Mr. President.
>> Any other discussion
comments?
Well, Director Hall,
>> I will just say for the record that um
there is a non-discrimination clause
which just requires us to not
discriminate against anybody in
providing services that are funded by
VAWA. Um that's the only thing I can
think of with regard to Mr. Nisley's
statement. um with regard to his um his
concerns about uh gun laws and folks
being deprived of their right to have
those weapons. Um
so there's always due process and the
guns that are taken, there's always a
receipt. Um and if the person is not
convicted, they get their gun back. But
if they are convicted, then it is the
position of my office and typically the
court that people who commit violence on
their family members should not have
access to guns um and should not have
them readily available because of the
significant increase in fatalities. Um
the risk of serious injuries and harm
goes up significantly. Um and so yes, if
you are convicted, we are going to take
your gun and we are going to keep your
gun. But that is not a VAWA. That is not
a VAWA requirement. That is not anything
to do with um the VAWA services we
provide. That's my position as the law
director for the city of Lancaster.
>> Okay.
>> Thank you.
>> Thank you. I'm just going to
[clears throat]
simplify it to a budgetary point. This
grant these grant funds do help us pay
for a a prosecutor. So, if you're not
signed up for for for new city council
members, there is a
an email you can get sent to your inbox
every day from the police department
that shows their daily calls, their
daily arrests, and then even more
specifically
certain things that are I guess bigger
cases requiring bigger response. And I
find it interesting there. It's
especially this time of year. I don't
know if it's cuz it's doom and gloom
outside, but everybody's cooped up.
There are so many more domestic violence
calls this time of year and it's it's
men and women um as the aggressors
there. It's shocking. It's it's pretty
even. But I just
we have that happening. So regardless of
of the other things, I think to be able
to get some grant funds to pay for a
prosecutor to deal with those, I mean,
you you got to kind of take some of the
lumps with it, um, if you will. So, it's
my position on that. Okay. Any other
discussion?
So, we're looking at a motion to pass.
Please call the role.
>> Mr. Als,
>> yes.
>> Mr. Bisjack,
>> Mr. Carr,
>> yes. Miss Cohen,
>> yes.
>> Mrs. Hoop,
>> Mr. Nicely,
>> no.
>> Mr. OG,
>> yes.
>> Mr. Skunover,
>> And Mr. Sully,
>> yes.
>> Motion to pass temporary resolution 7026
passes 8 to one.
Okay. temporary
resolution 826, 926, and 1026.
>> Okay, I will read them all. Uh
resolution temporary 826, a resolution
authorizing that announce certificates
for the payment of bills for November
and December 2025 in the environmental
engineering fund 7030.
This is through water water pollution
control committee, Mr. Als and Mr.
Bisjack.
Uh resolution temporary 9-26,
a resolution to set a 2026 revenue and
expense budget in the water construction
fund 626, water utility reserve fund
627, wastewater [snorts] utility reserve
fund 629 and wastewater construction
fund 630.
amend their certificate certificates
with the county of auditor and authorize
then announce certificates for payments
of bills again through water water
pollution control committee Mr. ALS and
Miss Cohen. And [snorts] then finally, a
resolution or for resolution temporary
10-26, a resolution to set a 2026
revenue and expense budget in the storm
water utility reserve fund 6019. Amen
certificate with the county auditor and
authorize that now certificates for
payment of bills. Again, this is through
water water pollution control committee.
Mr. Als and Miss Cohen.
>> Mr. Als.
>> Uh, yes, Mr. President. I move that we
suspend the rules and wave the third
reading on resolution temporarily number
826.
>> Second [snorts]
I can't do nine and 10. I have to
>> Can we do the amendment first and then
[clears throat]
>> Okay. Yeah.
>> So let's we'll skip I know it's out of
your order.
>> It's all right.
>> So if we do the amendments first then we
can still suspend all three of us. I
didn't want to go out of order, but if
you're saying that's okay, then I'm
happy to do it.
>> The bosses over there tell me we can do
it.
>> Yeah, that's fine. Go ahead. [laughter]
>> I'm a rule follower, so you know, I
don't
>> uh Mr. President, I move that we replace
uh temporary [snorts] resolution
and 1026 with 926 star and 1026 star.
Second.
All right. We have a motion to replace
926 with 926 star. 10 26 with 1026 star.
Everybody had a chance to see the
revisions. Correct. Okay.
Any discussion on this?
>> No.
>> No. Will you please call the role?
>> Um, Mr. Als,
>> yes.
>> Mr. Bisjack,
>> Mr. Carr,
>> yes.
>> Miss Cohen,
>> Mrs. Hoop,
>> yes.
>> Mr. Nisley,
>> Mr. OG,
>> yes.
>> Mr. Skoover,
>> And Mr. Sully,
>> yes.
>> Motion to replace passes.
9 to zero. Mr. Als,
>> uh, yes. I move that we pass. Nope, not
pass. We We need to suspend
>> suspend the rules and wave the third
readings of resolution temporarily
numbered 8, 9, and 10:26.
>> Second.
So, we have a motion, a second to
suspend the rules, wave the second and
third readings of temporary resolution
8, temporary resolution 926
star, and temporary resolution 1026
star.
>> Thank you.
>> You're welcome. Any discussion?
No. Please call the role.
>> Mr. Als, yes.
>> Mr. Bisjack,
>> yes.
>> Mr. Carr,
>> Miss Cohen,
>> yes.
>> Mrs. Hoop,
>> yes. Mr. Nisley,
>> yes.
>> Mr. OG,
>> Mr. Skunover,
>> yes.
>> And Mr. Sully,
>> Motion to suspend those three pieces.
Passes nine to zero. Mr. Als.
>> Uh, yes, Mr. President. I move that we
pass and engross and enter upon the
written record. Resolutions temporarily
temporarily numbered 8, 9, and 1026.
>> Second. [snorts]
So, we have a motion to pass the starred
version. Go ahead.
>> We've got to vote on them individually.
So, 826 and then 9 26 star, 1026 star.
Sorry.
>> So, we're going to
>> vote to pass on them individually.
>> Yep.
>> And don't forget your stars.
>> Yeah, I got them. I got them.
>> Gotcha. Okay.
>> Sorry, Lori.
>> That's all right.
>> We're just winging it.
>> Someone told me we could do all three
>> versus Yeah. All week I was trying to do
all 10 at once.
>> Doesn't [laughter] work.
>> I was the the [snorts] bad student of
the class. Everybody else shows up all
good and ready to go. Okay,
>> you're good.
>> Okay, Mr. President, I move that we pass
and engrossed and enter upon the written
record resolution temporarily numbered
826.
>> Second.
>> We have a motion and a second to pass
engross and enter upon the written
record temporary resolution 826. Any
discussion?
>> If anyone has any questions, Steve
Wilstead is here.
He's he's the pro. So, if you have any
questions on any of these three, he's
here.
>> Anybody? Any questions? [snorts] Seeing
none, we'll call the role.
>> Mr. Als, yes.
>> Mr. Bisjack,
>> yes.
>> Mr. Carr,
>> Miss Cohen,
>> yes.
>> Mrs. Hoop,
>> Mr. Nisley,
>> yes.
>> Mr. OG,
>> Mr. Scoover,
>> yes. and Mr. Sully.
>> Yes.
>> Motion to pass.
[snorts]
Temporary resolution 826 does pass 9 to
zero. Temporary resolution 926.
>> Uh yes, Mr. President. I move that we
pass.
>> Sorry. 926 star.
>> We pass and engross and enter upon the
written record resolution temporarily
numbered 926 star. A second.
>> Motion, a second to pass temporary
resolution
926 star. Any [snorts]
discussion?
>> I have none
>> from anyone else. Seeing none, please
call the role.
>> Mr. Als, yes.
>> Mr. Bisjack,
>> yes.
>> Mr. Carr,
>> Miss Cohen,
>> yes.
>> Mrs. Hoop,
>> Mr. Nisley,
>> yes.
>> Mr. OG,
>> Mr. Skunover,
>> yes.
>> And Mr. Sully,
Motion carries nine to zero.
Temporary resolution 1026 star.
>> Uh yes, Mr. President. I move that we
pass and engross and enter upon the
written record resolution temporarily
numbered 1026 star.
>> Second.
A
>> motion and a second to pass temporary
resolution 1026 star. Any discussion?
No.
>> No one else. Please call the role.
>> Mr. Als,
>> yes.
>> Mr. Bishack,
>> Mr. Carr,
>> yes.
>> Miss Cohen,
>> Mrs. Hoop,
>> yes.
>> Mr. Nisley,
>> Mr. OG,
>> yes.
>> Mr. Skooner,
>> And Mr. Sully,
>> yes.
>> Motion to pass 1026 star carries 9 to
zero. That's all I have for second
readings. Moving on to first readings of
resolutions. Starting with temporary
resolution 1126,
>> a resolution to authorize the service
safety director to enter into an
agreement with the Ohio Department of
Transportation to purchase rock salt for
the 2026 2027 winter season. This is
through public works committee, Mr. Carr
and Mr. Sully.
>> Mr. Carr,
>> first of two readings.
>> First of two readings on temporary
resolution 1126.
Temporary resolution 1226,
>> a resolution to authorize the service
safety director to advertise for bids
and enter into contracts for the
purchase of chemicals for use by the
division of water. This through water
water pollution control committee, Mr.
Als and Miss C.
>> Mr. Als,
>> uh, first of two readings.
>> First of two readings on temporary
resolution 1226.
Temporary resolution 1326. A resolution
to authorize the service safety director
to advertise for bids and enter into
contracts for the purchase of pipes and
fittings for the use by the division of
water. This is through water water
pollution control committee. Mr. Als and
Miss Co.
>> Mr. Als,
>> first of two readings, please.
>> First of two readings on temporary
resolution 1326.
Temporary resolution 1426. A resolution
to amend 2025 appropriation budgets and
amend the certificate of appropriations
with the auditor or the county auditor
in the escrow fund 80060 due to a
partial draw for the northwater plant
treatment or water treatment plant
replacement project. This through
finance committee Mr. Skoover, Mr.
Sully.
>> Uh it's going to be the first of two
readings.
The first of two readings on temporary
resolution 1426.
Moving on to temporary resolution 1526.
>> A resolution to authorize the service
safety director to accept Bureau of
Workers Comp compensation safety
interventions grant funds to increase
receipts appropriate from the unencumber
balance and amend the certificate of
other sources and appropriations with
the county auditor in the 0.15 levy fire
levy fund 2046
and to declare an emergency. This
through safety committee Mr. Mr. OG and
Mr. Skover.
>> Mr. OG.
>> Second of two readings.
>> Second of two readings on temporary
resolution 1526.
>> First of two readings.
>> First of two.
>> What' I say?
>> First of two. You said second of two.
First of
>> first of two.
>> Temporary resolution 1626. A resolution
to authorize the service safety director
to enter into grant agreements and and
to enter into contracts with various
consultants for the project known as the
east side industrial connector project.
This is through public works committee.
Mr. Carr and Miss Sully.
>> Mr. Carr.
>> First of two readings.
>> First of two readings on temporary
resolution 1626.
Temporary resolution 1726. A resolution
to increase receipts appropriate from
the unencumber balance and amend the
certificate with a county auditor in the
wastewater replacement and improvement
fund 6023 and to issue then now
certificates for the payment of bills.
This through water water pollution
control committee Mr. Als and Mr.
Visjack.
>> Mr. Als
>> first of two readings.
First of two readings on temporary
resolution 1726.
Temporary resolution 1826.
>> A resolution to amend the certificate
with the county auditor appropriate from
the unencumber balance increase receipts
and complete a fundto fund transfer in
the wastewater fund 6004 and in the
wastewater utility reserve fund 629. Mr.
through water water pollution control
committee. Mr. Als and Mr. Bisd.
>> Mr. Als
>> first of two readings. First of two
readings on temporary resolution 1826.
Temporary resolution 1926.
>> A resolution to appropriate from the
unencumbered balance and amend the
certificate of appropriations with the
county auditor in the wastewater
replacement and improvement fund 6023
and to authorize the issuance of then
announced certificates for payment of
bills is through water water pollution
control committee. Mr. Als and Miss
Cohen.
>> Mr. Mr. Hails.
>> First of two readings.
>> First of two readings on temporary
resolution 1926.
Temporary resolution 2026.
>> A resolution authorizing the service
safety director to enter into a contract
with EMH NT for design services to
appropriate from the unencumber balance
and amend the certificate of
appropriations with the county auditor
in the parks and recreation fund 2012.
This is through service committee. Mr.
Mr. Nisley and Mrs. Who?
>> Mr. Nisley.
>> First of two readings, please.
>> The first of two readings on temporary
resolution 2026.
Temporary resolution 2126,
>> a resolution to increase and decrease
the appropriation appropriations in the
wastewater utility reserve fund 6029.
Amend the certificate with the county
auditor and authorize the issuance of
the announce certificates for the
payment of bills. This through water
water pollution control committee Mr.
Als and Mr. Bisjack.
>> Mr. Als
>> Mr. President, I move that we wave the
rules and suspend the second and third
reading of resolution temporarily
temporarily number 2126.
>> Second.
>> We have a motion and a second to suspend
the rules. Wave the second and third
readings of temporary resolution 2126.
Any discussion?
>> No.
Any other discussion on the suspension?
Seeing none, please call the role.
>> Mr. Eels,
>> yes.
>> Mr. Bisjack,
>> Mr. Carr,
>> yes.
>> Miss Cohen,
>> Mrs. Hoop,
>> yes. Mr. Nisley,
>> yes.
>> Mr. OG,
>> Mr. Skunover,
>> yes.
>> And Mr. Sully,
[snorts]
>> Motion to suspend carries nine to zero.
Mr. Also,
I move that we pass and engross and
enter upon the written record resolution
temporarily number 2126.
>> Second.
>> We have a motion and a second to pass
temporary resolution 2126. Discussion.
>> Yeah, Curtis is here. If anyone has any
questions,
>> he's the guy that knows everything. So,
>> any questions before Curtis makes his
way up here?
>> Seeing none, you can stay put for now.
Thank you.
>> Thank you, Curtis. [snorts]
>> Seeing no further discussion, please
call the role.
>> Mr. Als,
>> yes.
>> Mr. Bisjack,
>> Mr. Carr,
>> yes.
>> Miss Cohen,
>> Mrs. Hoop,
>> yes.
>> Mr. Nisley,
>> Mr. OG,
>> yes.
>> Mr. Skunover,
>> And Mr. Sully,
>> yes.
[clears throat]
>> Motion to pass carries nine to zero.
Temporary resolution 2226
>> a resolution to authorize the issuance
of then and now certificates for payment
of bills for contract services is
through finance committee Mr. Skuniver
and Mr. Als
>> I'd like to make a motion that council
suspend its rules and wave the second
and third readings of temporary
resolution 2226.
>> Second.
>> We have a motion and a second to suspend
the rules. I have no discussion and
anyone else. Seeing none, please call
the role.
>> Mr. Als,
>> yes.
>> Mr. Bisj,
>> Mr. Carr,
>> yes.
>> Miss Cohen,
>> M Mrs. Hoop,
>> yes.
>> Mr. Nisley,
>> Mr. OG,
>> yes.
>> Mr. Skunover,
>> And Mr. Sully,
>> yes.
>> Motion to suspend carries 9 to zero. I'd
like to make a motion that council pass
and gross and enter upon the written
record temporary resolution 2226.
>> Second.
A motion and a second to pass said
resolution 2226.
We discussed this in finance. Anyone
have any questions on this one?
>> Seeing none, please call the role.
>> Mr. Als,
>> yes.
>> Mr. Bisjack,
>> Mr. Carr,
>> yes.
>> Miss Cohen,
>> Mrs. Hoop,
>> yes.
>> Mr. Nisley,
>> Mr. OG,
>> yes.
>> Mr. Skunover,
>> And Miss or I mean, I'm sorry, Mr.
Sully.
>> Yes.
Motion to pass carries 9 to zero.
Temporary resolution
2326.
>> Sorry.
>> A resolution to increase receipts
appropriate from the unencumber balance.
Amend the certificate of the with the
county auditor in the 045 police and
fire levy fund 2047
for CPT state grant reimbursement. This
is through safety committee. Mr. Bisjack
and Mr. Sully.
>> This will be the first of three
readings.
>> First of three readings on temporary
resolution 2326.
Temporary resolution 2426.
>> A resolution to authorize a then
announced certificate for the payment of
an invoice for enterprise fleet
management for the Langster Police
Department vehicle leases in the general
fund
and to declare an emergency. This again
is through safety committee, Mr. Bisjack
and Mr. Al. Mr. Bisj.
>> Thank you, Mr. President. I move that
council suspend its rules and wave the
second and third readings for the
resolution temporarily numbered 24-26.
>> Second. We
>> have a motion and a second to suspend
the rules on temporary resolution 2426.
Discussion.
>> Not at this time, Mr. President. Thank
you.
>> Anyone else? Please call the role.
>> Mr. Als, yes.
>> Mr. Bisjack,
>> yes.
>> Mr. Carr,
>> Miss Cohen,
>> yes.
>> Mrs. Hoop,
>> Mr. Nisley,
>> yes.
>> Mr. OG.
>> Yes.
>> Mr. Skunover.
>> And Mr. Salty.
>> Yes.
>> Temporary resolution
is suspended.
>> Yeah. I don't even know what I was
saying. Motion carries 9 to zero.
Mr. Bisjack.
>> Thank you, Mr. President. I move that
council pass and gross and enter upon
the written record the resolution
temporarily number 24-26.
>> Second. A motion and a second to pass
temporary resolution 2426. Discussion.
>> Thank you, Mr. President. Once again, as
I said earlier in the finance committee,
this authorizes the Langster Police
Department here to uh pay for the uh
lease agreement here for the unmarked
fleet vehicles that they have. That's
all. Thank you.
>> Anyone else? Seeing none, please call
the RO.
>> Mr. Als,
>> yes.
>> Mr. Bisjack,
>> Mr. Carr,
>> yes.
>> Miss Cohen,
>> Mrs. Who?
>> Yes.
>> Mr. Dley? Yes,
>> Mr. OG.
>> Yes,
>> Mr. Skunover.
>> Yes.
>> And Mr. Sully.
>> Motion to pass. Temporary resolution
2426 carries 9 to zero.
No more resolutions to come before
council tonight. So, we're going to move
on to reading of ordinances. There are
no third readings. So, we are going to
the second reading of temporary
ordinance 126. An ordinance to amend the
city of Lancaster zoning map to change
the zoning of 0.49 plus or minus acres
identified as Fairfield County auditor
tax parcel number 053
50005900
0 for mobile home community district to
commercial general district. This
through code enforcement and zoning
committee Mr. Sully and Mr. Nisley.
>> Mr. Sully.
>> Thank you Mr. President. I move that
council suspend its rules and wave the
third reading of temp of ordinance
temporarily numbered 126.
>> Second.
>> We have a motion and a second to suspend
the rules and wave second and third
readings of temporary ordinance 126. Any
discussion on the suspension?
>> I believe we covered this in the hearing
tonight. So,
>> okay,
>> we're good.
>> Any other questions?
>> Seeing none, please call the role.
>> Mr. Als, yes.
>> Mr. Bisj,
>> yes.
>> Mr. Carr,
>> yes. Miss Cohen,
>> yes.
>> Mrs. Hoop,
>> Mr. Nisley,
>> yes.
>> Mr. OG,
>> Mr. Skunover,
>> yes.
>> And Mr. Salty,
>> Motion to suspend carries 9 to zero. Mr.
Sully.
>> Thank you, Mr. President. I move that
council pass and engross and enter upon
the written record ordinance temporarily
numbered 126.
>> Second. A motion, a second to pass
temporary ordinance
126. Any other discussion?
>> Seeing none, please call the role.
>> Mr. Als, yes.
>> Mr. Bisjack,
>> yes.
>> Mr. Carr,
>> Miss Cohen,
>> yes.
>> Mrs. Hoop,
>> Mr. Nisley,
>> yes.
>> Mr. Og,
>> Mr. Scooter,
>> yes.
>> And Mr. Salty,
>> Temporary ordinance 126 passes
9 to zero.
Moving on to first reading of ordinances
with beginning with temporary ordinance
226,
>> an ordinance to authorize the mayor to
acquire payment and temporary rightway
as necessary for the memorial Pierce
Whittier new sidewalks project known as
the FAI-C33MR
7050-4.93
1.09. 09 project through public works
committee. Mr. Carr and Mr. Vichek.
>> Mr. Carr.
>> This is first of two readings.
>> First of two readings on temporary
ordinance 226.
Temporary ordinance 326.
>> An ordinance to amend permanent
ordinance 63-25, the management pay
ordinance, and to declare an emergency.
Mr. Finance Committee, Mr. Skover and
Mr. Als. I'd like to make a motion that
council suspend its rules and wave the
second and third readings of temporary
ordinance 326.
>> Second.
>> We have a motion in a second to suspend
second and third readings on 326.
I will forego discussion unless anyone
has any questions. Seeing none, please
call the role.
>> Mr. Als.
>> Yes. Yes. Sorry,
>> Mr. Bjack.
[laughter]
my brother.
>> We're all taking [laughter] a turn.
>> We're almost done. Hold it together,
people.
>> You're doing so well.
>> Mr. Big,
>> just had to lien it up a little bit, Mr.
President. That's a That's a yes for me.
[laughter]
>> Okay. Mr. Carr,
>> yes.
>> Miss Cohen,
>> Mrs. Hoop,
>> yes. Mr. Nisley,
>> yes.
>> Mr. OG,
>> Mr. Skoonover,
>> yes.
>> And Mr. Sullie,
Motion to suspend carries 9 to zero.
I will now make a motion to that council
pass and gross and enter upon the
written record temporary resol temporary
ordinance 326.
>> Second.
>> Have a motion and a second to pass
temporary ordinance 326.
Uh as discussed in finance, this is our
third go at fixing the number of
changing battalion chief to a assistant
chief. Any other discussion?
>> Seeing none, please call the role.
>> Mr. Als,
>> yes.
>> Mr. Bisjac,
>> Mr. Carr,
>> yes.
>> Miss Cohen,
>> Mrs. Hoop,
>> yes. Mr. Nisley,
>> yes.
>> Mr. OG,
>> Mr. Skunover,
>> yes.
>> And Mr. Sullie,
Temporary ordinance 326 passes 9 to
zero.
I ran out of ordinances. That's awesome.
>> Okay.
>> All right. We don't have any table
legislation.
We can move into unfinished business.
Does anybody have any unfinished
business they would like to discuss?
No. Anybody have any new business they
would like to discuss?
Okay.
I would entertain the announcement of
scheduled meetings.
>> I have next regular sessions of council
as February 23rd, 2026 at 6:30 p.m. here
in council chambers and then again in
March 9th, 2026 at 6:30 p.m. here again
in council chambers.
>> Okay. regular scheduled committee
meetings.
>> I have upcoming committee meetings. Um
service committee meeting scheduled for
February 12th, 2026 at 7:30 a.m. at 1897
conference room in city hall. I have
water water pollution committee meeting
February 13, 2026 at 7:30 a.m. 1897
conference room in city hall. I have
administrative committee me meeting
February 13, 2026 at 100 p.m. 1897
conference room in city hall. Public
works committee meeting February 20th at
2026 at 7:30 in 1897 conference room
city hall. And then the law committee
meeting February 20th, 2026 at 12:30
p.m. in the 1897 conference room in city
hall.
>> Thank you. Reading of bills. I have one
for $7063.
Um it was more than what I put on the
agenda. Um I grabbed the wrong one. And
that's for publication of resolution
um permanent resolution 2-26. And then I
just received the performer one today.
Um it's
at work. So I don't have the total of
that one yet. So that'll be approved
next one.
So, we're just Well, I'll make a motion
to pay the bill.
>> Second.
>> Motion in a second to pay the bill. All
in favor signify by saying I.
>> I.
>> All oppose. Same sign. Motion carries.
No need for an executive session.
And I will make a motion that we
adjurnn.
>> Second.
>> Second. I have a motion second. We are
adjourned.
One more for good measure.
>> Everybody have a safe trip home and